so another big story yesterday
the resignation of donald trump's
delusional
depraved dystopian uh what other d words
there's many
uh attorney general william barr he has
resigned
maybe he got fired as with all of these
things we never really know when a
resignation is claimed whether it was
really a resignation or whether it was a
firing
but donald trump yesterday saying that
indeed
william barr is departing on december
23rd sort of generally speaking the
reason given is that barr wants to go
spend time with his family
okay as you may recall um william barr
was it last week or the week before time
is so
weird right now in the last couple weeks
william barr
came out and said despite what donald
trump wanted bar to say
barr said as of right now there is no
evidence of election fraud
that would have any impact on the
election results and
donald trump didn't like this and many
republicans and trump didn't like it but
it was the truth
um and there were rumors that william
barr may be fired
and there were claims that donald trump
was thinking about firing william barr
this is being called a resignation at
this point in time
um donald trump tweeting as if it was
all super friendly
and super nice sort of a nothing to see
here tweeting quote just had a very nice
meeting with attorney general william
barr at the white house our relationship
has been a good one he's done an
outstanding job
as per letter bill will be leaving just
before christmas
to spend the holidays with his family
deputy attorney general jeff rosen an
outstanding person will become acting
attorney general
highly respected richard donahue will be
taking over the duties of deputy
attorney general
thank you to all now hilariously
barr's letter to trump is barely about a
resignation
it's a two-page letter the entire first
page
is weaponized brown nosing as i'm
calling it barr
thanks trump for letting him investigate
voter fraud
bar thanks congratulates trump on
operation warp
speed i mean just a completely
sycophantic letter it's just a riot
but then the second page is is like one
line
and on the second page bar just says as
discussed i will spend the next week
wrapping up and will depart on december
23rd
just a sort of casual i'm out of here so
the speculation
is that barr quit or was fired because
he refused to do the things trump wanted
him to do
i think it's really important to
understand that while that may well be
true
this actually reminds me of the brian
kemp situation in georgia
brian kemp is the republican governor of
georgia brad raffensberger is the
republican secretary of state of georgia
and when donald trump was insisting in
pressuring and pressuring
kemp and raffensberger to somehow steal
the election from joe biden in georgia
brian kemp and brad raffensberger
refused and there were people saying
look these are the
these are the good republicans they're
unwilling to do this stuff
remember that brian kemp is disgusting
brian kemp as secretary of state
ran for governor and participated in one
of the greatest acts of
election suppression voter suppression
in georgia
when he faced off against stacey abrams
it's not that brian kemp is a good guy
it's that for just about anybody there
is a low below which they will not go
there is the there is some place where
they say this i can't do
and brian kemp in all likelihood
recognized
that even if he was able to find some
completely authoritarian way
to try to steal georgia from joe biden
and give it to trump
trump still doesn't become president of
the united states and so brian kemp made
the political calculation that he wasn't
going to get involved
similarly william barr okay maybe barr
left because he wasn't willing to do
things trump wanted him to do or maybe
trump
fired barr because barr wasn't willing
to do it look at the things barr was
willing to do including that ridiculous
four-page propaganda letter
making completely incorrect claims in
advance of the mueller report like trump
was completely exonerated
when the mueller report said we cannot
exonerate donald trump completely from
obstruction so barr
is no good guy but it's certainly
plausible
that barr had to draw a line somewhere
it's also possible that barr wants to
get out before trump starts some really
humiliating stuff over the next month
which is expected to include some absurd
short-term appointments deranged
cronyistic pardons that
trump is expected to give even
borderline seditious last-ditch efforts
to steal the election so
bar is no good guy he's horrible he's
bailing out or was encouraged to resign
or was fired
and that is as far as we can say it uh
beyond that
bar is no one to be applauded think
about how much has happened
in the last three days we're so
desensitized
to the speed of the news the last three
days have seen coronavirus vaccination
start for a hundred year pandemic
the supreme court throwing out a legal
challenge on which trump and others had
hung their entire expectation for
stealing the election
joe biden officially winning the
electoral vote after five months of
trump's lies and coup attempts
and the attorney general william barr
either resigning or getting fired
all in the last three days on january
1st
we will have a huge one day
membership special to kick off 2021
strongly and i look forward uh to having
you
participate simply get on our mailing
list
at joinpacman.com to be notified on
january 1st
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration and they're giving
you
25 off your first order it's made with
four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great it's made with real
fruit juice it's been a great part of my
daily routine for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant
immunity packed with vitamins a b c and
d
which is also very much worth trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video